[voice over] They call those transformed by
the virus…Freakers.
[Deacon] Jesus.
[radio] What’s wrong?
[Deacon] Freakers.
[voice over] Are you ready to fight?
Hello, my name is David Lee, and I’m the
community manager over at Bend Studios for
Days Gone.
Our team has been developing Days Gone for
over 6 years.
At this point, I’m pretty sure we’re so
excited and enthusiastic for April 26 to come
because our team has put in so much time,
and there is so much space
solely dedicating to create such a wonderful
and unique experience for the PS4.
With our latest trailer release with the Sarah-Deacon
wedding, we see that Deacon is struggling
with the fact that his wife was taken away
from him by the pandemic that happened two
years ago in-game.
So especially with our game, our creative
director John Garvin has crafted a story
and these characters, you’re gonna want
to play through.
We talked about a 30-hour golden path, 6
hours of cinematics, and easily 100 hours
worth of gameplay
so I think anyone who’s interested in a
very narrative-driven story but
they also don’t mind driving around a very unique setting, then Days Gone is for them.
In central Oregon, anywhere really Oregon,
you’ll have to drive and in our studio,
they, especially our creative director, is very inspired by shows like The Walking Dead, Sons of Anarchy.
Closer to our studio, they actually know how
to ride motorcycles, so for them, they saw
this as a unique opportunity to bring into our game, which allows
different kinds of gameplay mechanics and different methods to go around.
As the game gets more developed, we’ve created
more ways to customise your bike
and really, at this point, I think there are
so many variations out there
that you really can spend hours customising
your bike and make it even better, so we’re
really excited about that.
I think, especially with our bike and wet
weather combat skill system is managed,
like in most games, in the very beginning,
you’ll struggle a little bit.
The game’s going to be hard and nonetheless,
it’ll be hard to go around, but the way
you can allocate your skill points
and especially the way you can upgrade your
bike, you can give yourself an easier time
but you’re going to have to make the hard
choice of “alright, am I going to put more
points or time into upgrading my skills?”
or “can I make my life a little easier with
the bike?”, or “can I take some time to
clear out some of the infestation zones?”
to make it so that I can maybe focus more on my skills, and not have to worry too much about
my second fast travel location.
I think if you want things to be easier in our game, you’ll have to take out those infestation zones
and take out all that landmarking on the map,
make it so you can fast travel on sea, have
less encounters with the Freakers.
The human threat is just as scary as the Freakers,
because you have ambush camps, people just
riding by wanting to take you out
because it’s after the pandemic, people who survived
an outbreak – they are not going to be nice,
they’re going to do everything to survive, just like Deacon, so you’ve gotta watch out for them.
The dynamic weather system we have in our
game plays an important role with gameplay,
with how you drive your bike, especially with
Freakers.
As it gets dark, during the nighttime – that’s when Freakers start to roam around, get more aggressive.
especially when it starts snowing, which kinda hardens the Freakers’ skin, gives them some more health,
and makes them more aggressive, so you always
have to keep aware of the weather on top of
just your normal struggles.
You’re constantly kind of on edge, on your
tippy toes, trying to find out what’s the best scenario.
As we talk about the Swarmers, you can see
any from one to 12, cause the Freakers
they like to stick together,
but then you have hordes, and that can be
anything from 50 to 300, and definitely more
than 300 as well.
But Newts, we have Screamers – we actually
showed off another type of Freaker in our
recent World [Series] trailer,
I cannot divulge any information, but he is
big, bulky, and if you see him, you’d want to run,
unless you feel confident to take him down, but there are more types out there that you can encounter
that you always have that second ear when
you’re playing the game, like okay, do I
feel confident to take him down
or should I just drive away and cut my cost.
The Marauders are just humans that are kind
of like Deacon, who pretty much do whatever
it takes to survive.
Two years, people who live past this pandemic
after two years, so you’d imagine they’ll
do anything to survive.
Regarding the Rippers, they’re pretty much
crazy people.
They…once the pandemic happened, they believed
it was a sign from God that this was a good thing,
so they cut themselves, they burn themselves
to be closer like the Freakers,
and they pretty much worship the Freakers,
so anytime you encounter them,
they’re kind of want you to join them or
they’re going to kill you, and you’ll
have to kill them, and they’re very aggressive.
We haven’t shown this kind of enemy types
yet, but you’ll see very unique types, especially
with the Ripper community.
What’s great about the system in our game
is that Copeland’s – that’s the first
encampment you encounter,
we have Maddie there, who’s actually a mechanic,
so he’s going to have the best bike parts.
But then, in the demo that you’ve had a
chance to play, you actually get to join Tux
Camp at the hot springs,
and out there, [it] has a good manage[ment]
of weapons,
so if you want better upgrades or better weapons,
you’re going to go to him.
We haven’t revealed all the camps yet, but know that each camp kind of specifies a different speciality,
and that you’re going to have to make the
decision of “okay, where am I going to focus
doing side jobs, or turning in stuff?” at
each of these camps.
I can say that…you know, our team has been working
on the game for so hard for the past 6 years,
we’re so excited to get our game Days Gone
into the hands of the PlayStation hardcore
fans and the casual,
and we’re so excited to see our game release
on April 26.
[voice over] Explore the world of Days Gone
at your peril.